each year Microsoft research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely
available so we're very happy to have
Arn Nan uh with us today U visiting from
Google uh who will be talking about his
research uh some of which is connected
to the d-wave machine and its
applications a subject that uh we're all
very interested in uh many uh people
have thought about it here in the room
um unfortunately Maus Troyer uh who's
has thought about it hard too uh
couldn't make it I saw him in Maria a
few days ago and he just wasn't quite
able to get here in
time but uh we'll do the best we can so
thank you very much for uh taking the
time to come up here yeah so thanks so
much for inviting me and honor to to be
here and um yes so I will um talk a
little bit about our work um training um
classifiers are doing machine learning
with Quantum optimization so a lot of
the Hands-On work is actually done by um
my student and collaborator vasil DF and
I also want to mention we we get a lot
of support from other teams so starting
with Edward far he who comes visit us
regularly and advis us on the project um
recently I have done um quite a bit of
work with v smanski um as you know USC
has a a DW machine and it's always nice
to talk to a second independent group so
s boo uh is our contact point there then
of course the the dwa team itself J Rose
B mcre and Muhammad Amin on the sir
side so um going to start out um with
the trivial observation like always in
computation um also in qu computation
you have a processing stack so there
different parts of the overall um
solution Pipeline and you typically
start out with some real world problem
which in our case happens to be in an AI
or machine learning most specifically
then in the next step we will map this
onto an optimization problem and then
from there we are map it onto a more
specific optimization problem a
quadratic unconstrained binary
optimization um that's still not good
enough yet um because you cannot give
any Cubo um as the guys call quatic
unconstraint binary optimization um you
cannot just give any of those to the
hardware the hardware can only realize
certain formats so that's the next step
and then on the bottom there's the
diabetic um Quantum computation
happening itself and then of course this
is supported by certain realization of a
cubits let's say um the super conducting
flux cubits in the case of um the dwa
machine so um my work has more been on
the um the top parts to to take an
interesting machine learning problem and
bring it down to an hard realizable Cubo
um while um that's a fair statement but
of course qu Computing still being very
early very early stages many people are
much more concerned with the pieces down
below here so how do we represent cubits
how do we protect cubits to preserve
coherence and other necessary Quantum
Resources um there's of course a lot of
work going on to understand what the
adiabetic algorithm can really do how is
the the Gap shrinking given certain
problems but um to to my
frustration even if these things down
here are perfect let's say the coherence
times are very long and a gap wouldn't
shrink that doesn't mean that you can do
something of practical relevance just
yet because these other parts if you
cannot map your problem onto the format
the the quantum um process or computer
can solve you're not making much
progress so these pieces seem to me a
little bit underappreciated um and the
work that needs to go into those even if
down here everything is solved to
Perfection um so the specific um problem
I'm discussing today is sort of the the
the most simple Main Street problem in
machine learning TR train a binary
classifier that has of course tremendous
practical applications think let's say
Google needs to make a determination
whether a certain email is Spam should
go into your spam folder or should show
up into the main email folder um that is
or whether certain image contains adult
content or not should be shown or not
but of course um outside of Google um
think of a bank making an automatic
decision whether certain person should
get a credit um uh or not based
on typically these things to are in
medicine should this patient um come for
a more in-depth check of a certain
condition or not um these are all
examples of a binary classification and
how these are um handled in machine
learning is you typically have a
training set that's labeled on positive
and negative
examples they live in in some some uh
feature space and then the task is to
essentially find them separating
manifolds that will'll say okay that
part of the input space we label as a
positive example and the other portion
be label as negative
examples and um so essentially what
you're trying to do you construct a
function where you take inputs um they
mapped onto binary labels y say minus
one + one and you have some function
that has a set of parameters that you
choose um that will Express essentially
X coming in some y coming out and
essentially learning them consists of
choosing the W such that it performs
well what does this exactly mean it
should perform well on new unseen
examples it's always easy we will see
doing well on the training set but
that's less interesting you want to be
good on the new unseen
examples so um you specific form of um
HW of X could be just a linear
classifier or um to make it a little bit
more expressive we can sort of what
depending on the subfield of machine
learning you're in you might call these
a functions AG um feature extractor or
you might call them weak learners but
overall you do a linear combination of
those and you still have an offset or
threshold bias um so here's essentially
listed um all the relevant um symbols
here again the main piece is there is a
set of of W's um that you want to choose
such that um you will do um small test
error or generalization error on unseen
example
X sorry in that formula should I would
have thought H or linear functions from
r no the X um the ages here don't
necessarily have to be linear functions
so we will um when I might have confused
you when I say this is a linear
classifier so in the in the simplest
case this would just be XI that that
would be truly linear classifier but
sometimes um we don't operate on the X I
directly but rather extract some
properties from the X via some functions
hi I then of course the overall piece is
nonlinear
classifi so XI would mean the I
coordinate of the vector X mhm
okay so the X I live let's say somewhere
in RM and are the input patterns to be
classified and your essenti the training
data consists of pairs X and Y where
sort of you get an input pattern and
it's um associated with a label plus
oneus
one so
um what is the right way to to pick the
W so that the um generalization error is
small so in modern machine learning this
is typically formulated as an
optimization problem and it's done in
the following way you get sort of pairs
um XS y s so we have let's s samples
examples to learn from and then training
is set up as an optimization over two
terms one is called the loss or
empirical risk and the other is the
regularization so um what are these two
terms doing so the loss essentially is
measuring in some way how well am I
performing on the training set so in the
easiest way something that people call a
01 loss you would simply count did I get
this example right or wrong given a
certain W so it's just measuring the
categorical error but
um this alone um is not good enough you
could essentially learn um sort of
examples by heart so to speak without
seeing the underlying um pattern in the
um train data so minimizing this alone
is not good enough you at the same time
um need to um take care of second um
element that is you want to the
complexity of your classifier to be as
um small as possible um so of course for
machine learning people that's an old
hat for for those of you who are not
that familiar with with it you can think
of um the
regularization as um let's say in
everyday scientific life sort of say the
simplest explanation tends to be the
best explanation and that's actually
true um you can actually prove to to
what degrees this is true um essentially
uh two classifiers um where one of them
has sort of lower complexity less fre
parameters um will you can prove that it
has lower bound the generalization error
and one that is more complex or another
um Point often shows this um maybe I
should quickly ask before going to how
many people have some background in
machine
learning guess then I should have
brought some extra slides um let's say
one easy way to understand the role of
regularization is the following let's
say you have some data and you um want
to model it with some polinomial then of
course if you take a very high order Pol
you will hit every data point perfectly
but as we all learn in undergrad uh
that's not necessarily a good strategy
um you don't really capture the tendency
or the natural law comprised in your
data so essentially to you need to
choose sort of the lowest um degree
polom that does a good job in explaining
the data that is typically sort of the
best way of of modeling the data you
have so you cannot overshoot in
complexity and that's sort of the second
term the regularization and and what
isg creation ARG um R is for regular ar
oh aren is simply um what um this a
setup um arment simply says um you want
to find the um you take that W as the
minimizer that essentially gives you the
lowest value of this objective function
okay and do you would you use some kind
of dimensional reduction to preprocess
your vector's XI or yeah absolutely
that's sort of earlier step yeah that's
earlier step actually I will come back
to that later um where actually we found
that directly related to how well we can
map itto the d-wave whole s we discuss
this on the later slide but yeah
absolutely um typically you you try to
get redundancy of out of your data
before you even start
um now in traditional machine learning
um these are two things to say the most
natural choices I gave you one example
for um a loss term you simply count how
many times do I get a training example
right or wrong now this Choice um makes
um L non-convex and therefore makes this
um optimization problem formally NP hard
um so people therefore um don't use 01
loss they instead use a convex
relaxation that's say exponential loss
or Square loss um same thing with
regularization you could maybe just
simply count let's say there's number of
bits or the number of free parameters
that you have in your classifier and try
to say give me the one that has the
smallest number again um that would be
referred to as L Zer Norm
regularization if you do this ch which
in some ways the most Natural Choice
again you have made a non-convex Choice
rendering and optimization formally and
be hard so
traditionally um in order to be able to
solve this optimization efficiently
people make um convex choices for l&r
and our will goes but you pay for this
in various ways you your learning is not
as good anymore in in various ways as we
will see so so
emboldened by emerging Quantum Hardware
we are
asking what can we gain if you leave lnr
nonconvex that will be studied now and
let's um we'll break this down let's
let's first study what happens if I keep
the regularization nonconvex and then we
will look what we can gain or how
machine learning can get better if if L
is cap and
so um let's start with non-convex
regularization so um essentially how we
set this up is the following we um can
start with our training set that's given
to us um here in this part of the work
we keep the
um the loss function of the empirical
risk we keep this to be convex we simply
use the square loss and in all to
express my losses I will introduce an
entity calls the margin and what is the
margin there's actually two definitions
of margin functional margin and
geometric margin but um I think for the
purpose of this talk we can um simply uh
look here at the geometric uh margin so
again my task is to separate the good
guys from the Bad Guys by putting let's
say some hyperplane between zones so the
margin essentially is the shortest
distance to this uh a margin for a given
example it's defined for an example is
the shortest distance to that uh hyper
plane and
um so so you see here the definition of
um of the margin and I want it to be
such that it's on the positive side so
if um my margin is um positive then I
correctly classified the example if my
margin is negative then I misclassify it
as this example so my classifier is just
a single is that if um yeah if I that
was um related to the question that um
Michael had earlier if I would just have
um taken the x i here yeah then it's
just a Hy that's that's a true linear
classifier that's the simplest you can
do yeah this you can also think as
another pre-processing step if you want
to wait you first sort of you don't
operate directly on your X but you sort
of um map it into some more suitable
space and in this more suitable space um
there you um have just operate
withes since since a margin piece is
important it comes a
lot since
I and S of some more of the so this is
my my margin earlier I um was referring
to the 01 loss 01 loss would look
something like
that so I I count the one if my margin
is negative see if if this expression
here is negative then essentially I
don't my classifier gives the incorrect
label to my example next and if it's
positive then my classify use the
correct label so that's the simplest one
that's 01 loss um of course if you let's
say would form for all your example the
sum you sum up all your losses
then this leads to non-convex function
so so people do these convex relaxations
and's say for example they put a an
exponential loss in there I put
square
square function there so these are
alternative choices those rendering the
problem convex um things like 01 keeping
it
nonconvex I had a question uh uh I'm not
understanding the concept of margin so
margin is defined just by some function
of course you're going to always get a
margin but it doesn't have to be
meaningful it could be a completely
absurd margin it looks like from the
picture that you have uh for the margin
to be meaningful your data set must obey
certain properties I mean for example if
I just had a bunch of rate points all
very close
together what will be the margin it you
know there will still be a formula that
formula still give as a carard that will
be totally meaningless so is an
assumption about what kind of data set
this is being processed margin is is a
very general concept of course the basic
thing is you have red points you also
have some Blue Points so essentially you
do a good job if let's say and here is
let's my positive examples the blue guys
and then here's a bunch of negative guys
so I want to essentially my task is if I
can find um a separating hyperplane so
that all margins are positive then at
least on my training set I will do a
perfect job it also tells you for
example um let's say here I have
multiple choices now I could have used
this hyper plane I could use this hyper
plane um I could have used this hyper
plane but obviously this guy here say
this here would actually be the best
hyper plane because um here is only a
very small margin while here sort of my
closest examples have larger margins so
since I have to assume that I might not
have seen all relevant examples in my
training set this is likely to be the
more robust choice
for confusing Shanker my guess is that
your illustration shows the red and the
blue point separated where in reality
they might be
interpers and then some of the
contributions to the margin function
would be negative if they were
completely on top of each other You' get
a 50 that's exactly
not very meaningful I understand exactly
mathematically what they doing but
suppose I had just the Blue Points then
this thing would not this good no no
you'd always have like half blue half
red or whatever but they'd be right on
top of each other yeah yeah that's what
I mean you can draw a line for those
blue and make one of them one have to be
there right and then that's of the
margin will be that SP fig would not
work very well
no let's say what I should say for
Simplicity I've drawn like people call
separable data sets separable you can't
draw a
hyper actually we will later discuss
this um let say Obviously could have
been like this that exing then these
guys too bad will margins and actually
will later discuss
um not I should say this here but in a
way it's natural if for example you have
what we call label noise let's say I'm
because where is my trending data coming
from in real life let's say some people
have looked at it and maybe I just no I
understand what you're saying only
comment I made that I understand the
margin can always be defined but what I
was saying I do not see this margin
being always very meaningful and I think
we agree that depending on the data set
this margin may not distinguish things
because just on top of each
other the margin is a function of the
classifier it just says a class with a a
small or negative margin
is looking at the
and then another you know point you
could see from the possibility of inter
Le red and blue points is of course you
could make a classifier that would
separate them that would be extremely
tortured but that would fail on this
regularization test you get a very
large okay yeah no I see from the
conversations
machine yeah yeah and of course um
there's no guarantee that that's called
it's called a base error if I have these
two um let's say if this is drawn from
distributions from probability
distributions that are interlocked that
have an over overlap then the what we
call the base error it's the best
possible error will not be zero so your
classifier will do finite error that's
unfortunately often
happening um so the um
uh regularization here I just choose to
be the uh l0 Norm um on my w Vector the
LZ Norm prob you all know simply counts
the number of elements of my w vectors
that are zero and of course the more I
have zero the least complex my
classifier and um so if I look at the
optimization that um is set up by adding
lnr this way you can see that you're
just spending of the order of n this
essentially the dimensionality of w
cubits to to represent um The Learning
problem and so since we discussed um of
regularization quite a bit I I show you
here a simple Guinea pck problem to to
see The Beneficial effects not only um
keeping it compact which means you can
run it faster but also in terms of
generalization error so here's the data
set um pretty simple one my my red and
uh blue points and then here I split it
apart I take um half of this data set to
be my um my training set and then the
let the solid points and then the um
less solid colored ones are my new uh
unseen um test examples that I will only
use during test phase and then we'll see
how well I do on those
so now you could see if you were to have
let's say as um weak uh classifiers this
these ages we talked about if you would
use this um AIS parallel hyperplanes you
could essentially cover your um positive
data by just four such hyperplanes and
um separate your negative uh guys in
this way now um without going to too
much detail if you use a very successful
and popular method in machine learning
called other boost and um actually other
boost does basically exactly um what
what we discussed earlier it constructs
um a classifiers this way um but
essentially you don't give yourself all
the ages at once what you do you just
start with with one age and you see how
well am I doing on my um on my data and
then you might see oh some I haven't
gotten quite right yet so what you do is
you boost those up you you maintain a
distribution um a weight distribution
over your training examples and the ones
that you haven't gotten right yet you
give it a little bit higher weight and
then the ones that you have a got done
right you lower their way and then again
you go into some pool of Ages that's
that you can choose from and then give
me the age that does um well or does the
best from all the ages I can pick on
this reweighted distribution and then
you you add this and you keep going on
sort of that the the guys that have um
sort of the hard examples they get
higher and higher weights So eventually
will pull in an age that will do well on
those um so that's algorithms is called
ad boost and if you just go to um your
FR who actually FR and shapir have um
developed other boost and just go to the
side and you has a little interactive
Java Outlet where you can um input this
data you will see eventually converges
to something like this so um it has
these breakout regions so where are they
coming from if you look closely in the
breakout region essentially there was no
training example given so the classifier
will do a nice job in say oh if I just
separate sort of the space into a
positive and negative region in this way
I I do fine on my training set by just
um you know separating in this way
because these breakout regions or here
in the intermediate run um of the
algorithm you have other breakout
regions they don't hurt you on the
training set but um again this is an
illustration of the role of
regularization um here you need more
hyperplanes to express sort of these
breakout regions you could have gotten
away with just sort of four ages four
ages um could have boxed in your
positive examples but here other boost
traditionally is not run with any
regularization and then it would yield
those breakout regions and then of
course if you present a new Test example
that happens to lie in those then you
will do cause an error on those so you
see the does aut boost pay attention to
this margin
function um does it other boost does it
uses um an exponential essentially other
boost works with an exponential loss
function so um essentially yeah over the
margins so because in your example even
though you successfully avoided the
training data the hard this bright red
dots you came very close to a lot of
them I'm wondering why that was
permitted that's that's a very small
margin right say right hyper planes they
are you you only see sort of where it
all sums
up lower right
picture yeah the same hyperplanes would
be used um M if you made it tighter
you'd lose the blue ones that's the
problem if you move way then
you bottom well I'm talking yeah I'm
talking about both blue bars they're
dark red dots very near the periphery of
the blue stripes
but if you try to move in close further
then you lose the blue in the center and
then you're going to lose you're right
in the edge of how far you can go before
you start losing the positive examples
but
U
compos excess parallel
hyper if you move them a little bit more
to the left let's say you might already
inquire sort of a negative margin which
the alith doesn't like why doesn't the
AL
find what's the difference actually I
don't know how to refer to your your
panels uh is see two different
algorithms no so sort of C is sort of
the optimal thing you could do if sort
of your ages would be um ex parallel
hyper
planes essentially each hyper plane
separates on it own the space positive
into a negative area and this is sort of
summing up four such ages
one yeah each um side of this
square is essentially the hyper PL would
look like
this but just so I can refer ask
question let see six
p this is let's
say positive here and there's another
one it's positive this
direction so what you see here the blue
thing is essentially sort
of adding up of these four hyper ples
that box it
in these are the stages this is
essentially the algorithm running as you
go let's say if you go to the t is just
sort of ative algorithm okay so this
after 10 iterations 20 640 after which
it doesn't change
anymore and C C is kind of without any
of those C is is um just sort of true
this would be the optimal oh that's some
thing you just thought that's not
exactly like let's say if you say I give
myself a family of Ages of that nature
the best you could do would be C say the
AR boost and a very successful method
does that so so it does two things also
640 means it uses 640 hyper planes as
opposed to just four so it would run
much much slower moreover it has a lower
accuracy how many how many dimensions
the problem he have I mean you're kind
of drawing it as a two dimensional
problem yeah this just two
dimensional this is a toy problem we
supposed to see 640 hyperplanes def
finding those purple
regions yeah there a whole bunch of
hyper ples not necessarily see here not
necessarily all again what what you see
is essentially where you sum it up where
it's larger than a threshold and where
it's slower than a threshold yeah so
there are 64 hyper planes involved but
you wouldn't necessarily see them all
here in this your learning would have
shown though around between 20 and 640
you probably could have sto earlier you
could probably
have is changing
that yeah essentially
as you look at your um training error
as the Air's probably not changing that
dramatically between T20 and t640 that's
correct necessarily yeah you could have
used
your but of course in boosting but I
don't want to go too into this in
boosting you typically don't necessarily
stop when you're training error zero um
you still look sort of um because in
light of what we said about the margins
you look how sort of your average margin
is still um getting larger so you're
typically are well off to go on even so
your training error is already zero it's
typically done in boosting would you go
all the way to 640 um maybe not I just
let it run until when it stabilized that
didn't move further we would have some
fairer comparisons this is just an
illustration of the role question so if
you have more hyper planes than data
points what is it like it seems like if
you have as many hyper planes as data
points you could just B small box on
every Point yeah that's probably a case
of severe overlearning people over you
violated um drastically sort of the um
desire to keep to the um classifier
complex and you have have essentially
learned by heart every training example
that's given to you as opposed to having
understood hey there is this structure
where there is this little cluster
surrounded by some other um
examples so yeah that's actually
question and of course you can see this
is just a two-dimensional example um as
you typically data is much higher
dimensional so these break you have much
more opportunity for these breakout
regions because say you cannot fill 100
dimensional space dense enough the the
algorithm often will oh I could have a
positive area here I could have a
positive area here without any penalty
on the loss the only thing that is your
Saving Grace is irregularization I would
tell you don't do this just use the
smallest set but again other boost is is
a greedy algorithm it's not a global
optimization things so so you I think
this discussion shows you a little bit
sort of where the machine Learning
Community is and how you start to look
at these problems very differently if
you say no no let's not just do it
imediately add one by one and then
produce these funny artifacts let's take
sort of a global look what is
essentially given let's say I have a
bunch of of hyperplanes or we
classifiers I can choose from what is
sort of the smallest subset I can pick
such that I do a good job on my training
set that is sort of the question we are
asking um you using Global optimization
for machine learning but asking this
question is asking to solve an NP hard
problem hence s of the motivation to do
this on a quum
machine um so we spend quite some time
on this sort of this is see more um uh
formal way it's probably one of the most
important results I would think in um
machine learning which essentially shows
you it's it's called set of the um VN
chovis bound which comes from the chovis
dimension which essentially is um a
dimension that characterizes the
richness of your classifier how many
different labelings essentially can you
do of data that you have gotten and um
the lower you CH so it's essentially a
measure for the complexity of your
classifier um and the lower the
um this Dimension the better is your
bound on the generalization error so you
can prove that if you are Frugal if you
use a less compact classifier you will
have a lower bound on the generalization
eror so you're guaranteed to do better
and
essentially you you see there is this
term T in there which is sort of the
number of classifiers used if I knock
this down I will be assured to have a
better generalization
eror
um so maybe I
um skip this this piece um it is
essentially we discussed the main ideas
but of course um we haven't really
discussed let's say if the
um the classifier I want to construct or
need to construct to do a certain
classification task what if it needs
more um classifiers so it's a diens of w
needs to be larger than the number of Q
of cubits I have what do I do then then
I need to to to break it up somehow so
so first um observation I'm not
completely confused I know you have
noticed you have used the word Cubit
where is quantum mechanics in all the
things you talked so far I mean what is
this Cubit he so far there is no quantum
mechanics this is just a nure this yeah
essentially of course later in the later
parts we will
bring so far there was nothing mean this
is just a name is just a name yeah yeah
exactly let's um yeah it's a name later
of course we will want to solve the
problem on the quantum chip and then I
have to ask myself the question um what
if the problem is larger than the number
of um variables I have available on the
chip and essentially there's um uh
sort of these two strategies uh come to
mind one is um if I have um can get away
with a classifier that needs less weak
classifiers than I have cubits then I
can sort of run the following enrichment
process I earlier explained you how you
do boosting by sort of reweighting your
examples and sort of greedily picking
the best one sort of with global
optimization you can say you do this
with a group you say okay
um I um can afford looking at up to um Q
such classifiers we classifiers so now
I'm asking the question what is this the
subgroup T the most compact subgroup
that does well in terms of of loss in
terms of error on my training set and
then I get let's say some set back Q
minus t and the others will be set to
zero um by virtue of my um zero
regularization and then I can say okay I
have these Q minus t spots left open so
I can sort of do exactly the boosting
idea rewe my training set and and I say
oh on which training samples do I still
have problems and I find new ages that
are good on these problem cases and I
throw them into my um into the mix I I
freeze theq guys I had before and I fill
the remaining spots with these
specialist so to speak and run the
optimization again and um if I were to
be assured that I could always find as a
global minimum I could only get better
because the old solution is still
available if that was the best solution
I would get it again and I would
terminate there but um if there's a
better solution to be had now because I
throw in these experts I would find that
so I could go on so it's like an
enrichment process I find it's a quite
nice sort of global optimization version
of boosting and I I do this until I'm
happy but it could be of course that my
classifier needs to be that big That's
Not Unusual to see a classifier that has
a thousand um let's say where a w needs
to have the dimensionality of a thousand
so that's larger than any say dwa chip
today then the strategy would simply be
I run this as the inner loop until I'm
happy then I I freeze this part of my
classifier and then I add another chunk
um and repeat this inner loop so so
essentially the first part gets Frozen
and then this part is still L up to so
let me ask a question about resources so
I was expecting that uh the number of
cubits would be related to the number of
data points in your training set in this
case it's not the case unfortunately in
the next storing it will be the case
here it's not the case it's independent
that's actually why it's my only example
that Maps really well onto the D
architecture because it's really only
dependent um so I only need but how you
but at some point you must enter the
training data into the dwa chip
no yeah but but this only enters sort of
in a summed up form um I actually don't
have this formula here right now but but
you see that the number of the variables
you need the coefficients um let's say
in your quadratic program will depend on
training on the data set but only in
terms of sums not sort of explicitly so
you only need of the order of n
variables cubits um to become cubits
later on so that's a nice thing about
um the situation where we work with a
non-convex regularization but still
keeps the um loss function convex in
that case the number of variables is
independent of the size of the
training
unfortunately I could dig up the paper
it's pretty clear if you write down the
um the number of cubits um must be
related to uh the number of parameters
the dimensionality of the data points
not the number of data points um what's
the relation there yeah so so um right
if you we discussed this earlier if
let's say here's the H I let say we
would use directly x i then yeah then
you write the number of cubits is
related to the input um space space
dimensionality but is there uh is there
an exponential there that is uh if you
have n Cubit then you have uh to the end
dimensional complex space of State
vectors that the cubits
represent know of course um as n grows
sort of the um let's say the number of
different classifiers that you could
express would grow exponentially as 2 to
the N um but the number of cubits you
you use is only um of the order of n
that's capital N which is the but but
that Capital if I'm remember correctly
your notation that's the number of
Elementary classifiers
classif the weight on those class right
but but I'm trying to understand the
relationship between the number of
cubits and the dimensionality of the
data yeah in it's think of a simple case
here where the um I mean I mean
eventually the entire dat said this is
entered into a vector in hbert space is
that correct
um there's no h but space yet at this
point it's still strictly um classical
so if you if you're um classifiers of
this nature I have eliminated um so I
goes from one to n these guys here will
be encoded um will work we haven't
discussed yet that I'm allowed to do
this because normally those weights are
real value and numbers but I will show
you later an arguments that we can cheat
and actually treat this as discret um uh
low bit
deps okay let me just something that
confused me earlier but I didn't ask um
shouldn't X have a different index XJ or
something instead of x i because X is a
point in RM and uh I ranges from 1 to n
I think should be H that that's should
be H oh he got rid of the H in this
case that was earlier when we had the
remapping H it's not an
X I'm what's the subscript on X is it an
i or j i are all
three so those letter I because then I
don't understand I thought yeah the
index one to M and the other one
nten rid
of function so
be a j really no oh
no instead of a weight per this is a
special you can think of the AG as sort
of
mapping you can think of as sort of
mapping you can either work on let's say
let's make a conrete
example you can think of the ages can we
call it this let's say one example would
be the X's could be images and say it
could be 32 by 32 pixel images and show
faces and I do a face detect and say
it's a face are not P that would be
working directly on the raw images in
this case often you don't do this you
don't okay work on the exis on the
images you extract some features let's
say gabora wavelets or fer components or
something more suitable that you extract
from the image this would be my ages
okay so let me just ask a question will
check my understanding I I hope capital
Q has to be larger than or equal to log
of n is that
right no um Q has to be
Q is the number of
qits is it true that Q is larger than l
no Q has to be just larger than
unfortunately has to be larger than than
n again there a quadratic oh but then
it's larger than l i mean because you
said n so the answer is yes in this yeah
yeah it's yes I'm just it's true but I
feel there's some misunderstanding
L Michael the hes no don't be afraid of
that will take all
think of the H's is taking all M of the
X's one of the H's and mapping it to
something it's a mapping function so you
can think of that's why there's no
subscript on his X in there it takes all
the x's and a given H will map them to
something like take a 4 a transform or
Gabor function or whatever so this is
kind of I think this actually makes it
less clear in some respects because the
idea is I'm going to take my entire data
set or said No in fact it's a form of
initial dimensional reduction yes that's
all it
is the data in M dimensional space and
you're turning it essentially to n
dimensional
space some linear preprocessing maybe
some
nonar
press okay but but why does the number
of cubits have to be greater than n
rather
than this Cas wanted to be exactly like
yeah if if my W's are um let's
say
binary which they normally um will come
to an argument why I'm allowed to L this
because
normally this expresses my classifier so
so it's a family of classifiers
parametrized by those W's and I want to
pick the W that does a good job in terms
of training error and in terms of
regularization being cover neck I want
many of these wi to be zero so so that's
the optimization I run over that's what
I'm going to set up as an optimization
problem essentially to find when you
asked earlier what's this Arc mean so
what I want to get out of them I mean I
set up the objective function such that
the W that does best in terms of loss
and regularization is the global minimum
of my
optimization thank
you okay let me just keep a track of
time should take a little extra time
sorry um okay so we we looked at this we
understood the role of
um so yeah I should show you a sort of
results on on data sets but I wanted to
um point out that uh quick that this is
of big um of uh practical relevance to
have compact class
for for example know fir hand Google
Glass actually has a whole bunch of
detectors on them many I'm not known yet
but you need to um uh run this on very
little battery power so how can you run
these things for a long times um of
course you will have some fpga
implementation or some microcontroller
these guys are very grateful if you have
an algorithm that say listen I do your
detection whatever that needs to be um
and give you a very compact classifier
that can do this with sort of the least
amount of of cits and that's sort of the
Practical view on what L Zer Norm has
these two advantages this gives you
better accuracy as we discussed in the
other boo example but it also will
execute at execution time the um
classifier will be faster also this
gives me an opportunity we have
structured the our approach such that we
only use um the Quantum algorithms
during training so once I have my
classifier it's a completely classical
machine again that I can run on a cell
phone I can put it onto Google Glass or
of course the NASA guys with whom we
collaborate quite a bit they have the
same challenge if you just have sort of
solar powered Rover on Mars and you want
to do local detection there that you
don't have to send the signal back to
Earth wait 10 minutes until you get a
signal back um all these are nice
applications for very compact detectors
it's also Microsoft Connect
yeah pervasive even though that's pluged
to the wall plug so you might
um okay so in the interest of time I'm
not sure I should should cover this um
and probably only bothers people who are
in have a sort of preconception on
machine learning normally when you open
up a machine learning book these wi will
be real value numbers now that's already
a bad start right there given that we
ultimately have can only do binary um
optimization on the dve chip so you
essentially have to of course you can
always um let say I do I E standard and
express to a binary expansion of my real
valued number let's say 264 um bits I
can do that but that's of course a coor
strategy if my chip has just 12 8 or 512
um cubits um then sort of such a poor
encoding will just allow me to
do a few um there input dimensionality
would have to be really small so
fortunately we found empirically that
you're often better off by using W's of
very low bit depth so you only use two
three four bits to express it and often
you actually
doing the best job by just using a
single bit so that's a pervasive um
observation we made actually this was
part of how um sort of I I got into that
part we had actually little anecdote
here we had to deliver a face detector
to that was prior to me being at Google
having a startup company delivering
Vision routines and we um had a a
Japanese I think Doo um t phone
manufacturer who wanted a face detector
on their phones and at that time sort of
memory on phones was still very scarce
and it's goes like on the stock market
they tell you weeks before Oh you get
that much memory and just before the
launch sort of they reduced the memory
we were allowed to to use tremendously
and by then everything was trained were
kind of done and oh my God we can't do
that and then the engineer in charge the
only thing I know is do is I instead of
using let's a float for these guys I
will just use a few bits and he did this
and the performance actually got better
and um and by now many other people have
looked at this we see this again and
again on all our tests we see that
you're actually better off and it goes
back to the regularization point in a
way you on a bit level you use the most
um compact classifier by expressing your
W's um with low bit depth this nice
geometry here is actually an argument um
that makes this more intelligible why is
this empirical observation and
essentially in w space every example if
if I give you an example
then there a will be a hyperplane in w
space say if you take W's on that side
you will classify this example correctly
if you choose the W on the other side
you will do it incorrectly so you get a
bunch of examples or you get a bunch of
of hyperplanes that spend this polop and
then the solution spaces so essentially
the the solution which let's say has the
smallest training error you have to hit
one of those spaces and if we simply
counted those spaces and sort of derive
this sufficiency condition let's say if
I'm really working only on a hyper Cube
or on a hyper lce then all I have to
make sure is that sort of I hit if I
have a representative in each of these
Chambers um so of one point on my hyper
lus is located in each of these Chambers
I'm good I can use this point and it has
sort of the training um Power of or will
do on my training set as well as all the
other guys in this chamber and you see
that only grows logarithmically with the
ratio of training examples to weak
classifiers all the input dimensionality
n so it's only logarithm of s Over N so
grows very slowly um as your examples
this is basically linen
stra oh subject linen stra comes in
label I think this one here's the same
one I think it's called sour Lama
actually this sort of was known before
we kind of rediscovered it by the way um
since you mentioned w space seems to me
there's an interesting Duality between
data and classifiers because you can
think of a data point as a classifier on
classifiers that is you can say which
classifiers get that data point correct
right so the data point sort of draws a
a line through the space of classifiers
yeah it's very true if you have linear
class well but it wouldn't be a line
that could be uh it separates the
classifiers in any case so I'm wondering
whether you can work back and forth
uh using that Duality that you can train
your classifiers on data and then train
uh the data the class part that's an
interesting s i Haven I don't know other
folks in machine learning I haven't come
across that but that sounds like a compe
tet or something yeah no that's
interesting
obervation
um okay so um now let's um go to to
something more more exciting so so I
this is the nice thing about this story
is it Maps well to the hardware you
don't need a tremendous amount of cubits
and the advantages you get is somewhat
increased accuracy and um nice
compactness which needs to to fast run
time good for power constraint
environments and the next piece I find
personally much more exciting and zel
now we switch we had discussed sort of
um non-convex r nonon regularization but
now let's look at what happens if you
use a non-convex loss and I think that's
if you can solve this would be true Step
Up in Ai and um here I will
um sort of think but now this figure
again our positive points or negative
points we want to separate it um and
let's say initially the data and was
linearly separable so you could have put
sort of the base classifier that is sort
of the best classifier can come up with
with the lowest error on the true
distributions that are assume
probability distributions assumed to
underly your
data um but now in real life you often
have in particular if you use huge data
sets um there's always noise in the data
and even if human labelers are involved
a little anecdote we were responsible
for doing sort of the face blurring in
Street so we had to find the faces and
the license plates and blur them out so
in order to get more data for the um
street view cameras and not just use our
standard pH detector we wanted to
fine-tune it a little bit because
countries like Switzerland they want
99.9% of all the faces BLT out um so we
have a large Operation Center in India
we Shi sort of um lot of Street panamas
their way and they please label them for
us put U bounding boxes around the faces
so so they did um but what I lost in
communication was they didn't label the
one that's on
billboards so which tend to be a
goodlooking specimen normally of of
faces so those were not in there and of
course sort of the the um the training
gets badly thrown off by this so now you
have all these good-looking faces that
IR the images and you tell them that's
not a pH so that's considered label
noise yeah so so how would this look
here this would mean that let's say
these were the um the faces you would
tell for a few these are really nor
faces so that is bad for any convex um
loss why is this it's a little bit
like we get the grees so these guys
coming to your point earlier these will
have negative margins now so they would
lie somewhere here let's say even for
the base classifiers this would be
negative Marin and if you do a convex
relaxation then there's a very high
penalty on those so your optimization
will completely stare at getting these
guys right and you can imagine this will
distort completely the result you you
get back therefore there's a paper byong
the video that says all convex losses
can be defeated by labor noise and um so
this this figure um so of if you do a
non-convex loss the situation is not
that bad uh essentially what you allow
your optimization to do is say as you're
looking for W's and then find the right
W actually if there are a couple of guys
that you need to sacrifice you can do so
you can misclassify them and you pay a
penalty of one for each of those guys
but not more than
that so this is a general the covering
all kinds of data structures or what
there some assumptions about how much of
those unclassified I is a mathematical
theorem in the sense Michael accepted
the theorem yeah here so this
un new paper um it's actually a very
it's simple proof but there were um it's
on the archive manani and SRI that show
The Following that 01 loss is robust up
to 50% of label noise so you can um
pollute your data of course if it's more
than 50% and you tell it more more often
this is not a face
then exactly but um so if um you have
say if there's a clean data set let say
there a real fais that can be classified
with 0% base error if um sort of your
your feature extractions Rich enough
that it would do a perfect job on the
clean data then you can if you were to
train in this data set you may never see
it's is just a hypothetical thing if
there's a data set on which you would or
if on the clean data set you would do
well classify it correctly then you can
collude it with up to 50% label noise
and still retrieve the base optimal
classifier that's a real big deal why is
this a big deal because let's say I
don't want to right now let's say the
different machine Learning Systems where
we have at Google if you look at what
you call Google brain is this huge deep
belief Network or um let's say support
Vector machines boosting stuff for each
discipline and machine learning have
like nice big engines as that do it but
if you look how they perform from
algorithm to algorithm they're sort of
within a very narrow band regardless of
which approach if it's a Well tuned
approach they're all about the same if
you double the amount of training data
or you tenfold your amount of training
they all move up so it's maybe a little
bit sad for machine learning guys that
tell them there smarts is not nearly as
important as the amount of data we can
give the Learners and but to get to good
training data is that's expensive you
know I just explained you the story with
how to ship the data to to India to to
get it labeled it would be so much nicer
if I could just go let's say I want to
do a car detector how nice would it be
if I could just go to image search and
punch in cars so views of cars and then
let's say look at the first 100,000
results it will be a long of valid
training examples but then there will be
the Ferrari keychain the pory coffee Muk
and so on stuff that is not cars but if
I could train with 01 lost and if all
I'm assured there's less than 50% of my
data and image search is is not really
cars but would still be good so this is
Al to me a true horor Mark for
intelligence eventually your teacher
tells us this and then essentially what
this system is able to do is to say you
know what I don't believe you're telling
me the right thing on this example or
actually this one I think should be done
differently so you you see there is a
huge reward if you could um train with
with 01 loss or um similar story hold
for other non-convex losses so
um yeah that's a the second part of our
work where we um we kept actually we
could have kept this zero Norm also but
yeah just happens to be that is a loss
we we do L2 Norm so it's a convex loss
but the um sorry convex regularization
but the loss we use the so-called Q loss
so why is it Q loss if you know that the
machine dwa machine can do quadratic
optimization so essentially we didn't do
like exact 01
loss but we did sort of one where this
comes off as a little Parabola here so
can see this here so has a little
Parabola piece and you have a parameter
Q which can sort of make this Parabola
piece
shorter um it would have the same
properties um but it will map better
onto the d-wave architect so went over
this
so now if how can you express such a
thing as a quadratic uh optimization
problem if you have a loss that looks
like this
um not
immediately clear so the technique we
used is um called variational
approximation so essentially
um this approach works such that if you
have a complex function or we would
rather have a sum over such functions
that you want to optimize say use a
simpler set of functions for example
parabas um but use a whole family of
them and you introduce an auxiliary um
set of variables T essentially T tells
you where sort of the parabola has its
minimum and then you
co-optimize over T you find the right
Parabola and the lowest point on the
parabola so essentially is a more
complex function I was expressed as a t
parameterized family of parabolas and
you can this related to proof how you
can show that um indeed by using this
approach you have um expressed the
function you were interested in this
goes by the name of convex
Duality to show this little proof and
then if you do this then you get sort of
this um somewhat ugly looking expression
but it's essentially the the the same
thing we have the W to is the second
parameter we always sort of ignore this
is a threshold of my classifier if you
want to you can always express it as
another element of w and then there are
these auxiliary um hidden parameters T
I'm not really interested in those that
just happen to come along for the ride
um and but this expression here is now a
quadratic um optimization function
pretty complex but it's a quadratic
optimization actually you have to still
go one step further because here this is
still real value W so I still have to do
sort of the short um bit depth binary
expansion and if I do that then the
expression fills a whole page but the
structure is just this it's a quadratic
unconstrained binary optimization so in
principle something you can feed to the
dve
machine so
um May quickly rushing through these are
actually results I haven't shown you any
results I just told you what you can win
if you could work with non-convex
regularization and what you could get if
you were to work with a non convex loss
so here I'll show you um some results so
this are essentially results from where
we compared performance of all
classifiers on a data set which can look
very much like what I showed you
essentially the positive and negative
examples were drawn from um Gan
distributions and to your question we
made it harder and harder by pushing
those Gan distributions into each other
So eventually the base error is not zero
anymore because those distribution
overlap you will have a fight based
error the base error actually would be
um 005 so it would be about here and
then we compared um other boost
and we compare different versions of the
quantum algorithm this still not running
on the d-wave machine yet this is just
using taboo search sort of a discrete uh
euristic solver as a stand in for theum
Hardware um but you see that you do sign
on this very simple set you do
significantly better in terms of error
rate so here this is at one the two gos
are perfectly overlapped um so that's
the hardest spot here so you do
significantly better than than let's say
Al boost um as a method that we compared
against three different implementations
of Al boost some question that I'm
getting asked often here what about
other boost with L1 regularization
that's still efficiently solvable yes we
have done this too but um in this case
here um the i1 regularization um will
perform worse um than the standard other
boost think that is but um as so that
what we got on that data set this is
another data set scabo wavelets
extracted from eyes to say here's an ey
or is not an ie and then here you can
see let's say the number of we
classifiers you earlier said herey I
wouldn't really have used
640 yeah here's a more fair comparison
other boost selected um in average um
257 classifiers while um the uh discret
Global optimization version with L zero
Norm only used 116 we classifiers yet
getting a lower test error why are the
training errors so high on the the
training error on adab is quite low and
then the training and the others are you
know Test air more closely which is a
sign for for over learning the other
boost side which is maybe not surprising
given that you have these two oan clouds
going into each other
um so this is where we work with
non-convex losses um again this is not
yet running on the the dwa machine we
used different um Benchmark data sets
from the UCI Benchmark the database of
machine learning problems and some
problems that were earlier quoted us
this paper that shows that how convex
losses can be defeated so say design
design some data sets for this so we use
those and it works beautifully on those
the red curve is essentially Q loss and
then we compared against a whole set of
linear essentially svm logistic
progression T logistic is another um
non convex um approach to to training
and the key Point here is we don't make
any claims that our way of non-convex um
using a non-convex loss is better than
others we only say we should have
principal advantage over um convex uh
losses and you can see that um in some
cases we even have a test error that is
a whole order of magnitude lower um than
what you get with convex losses that's
in machine learning you typically don't
see such papers now it's like a few per
here a few per there um but in in the
high noise regimes in certain cases we
have up to um Factor 10 lower
test and even here even though this was
L2 Norm but because we work with few
bits let's say if you have only one bit
or only four um or two bits so only four
different values for your W the chance
that it's zero is already increased as
opposed to you working let's say with 64
bit weights chance that this exactly
zero is is Vanishing so so as I
understand a a trade-off you have
theorems that say that non-convex was is
much more a robust
tool particularly against label error
but on the other hand the optimization
problem is the solution to your AR Min
is going to be uh in general mty part so
roughly what you're doing if I
understand it is you're sort of
Designing a front end for the d-wave
machine which is intending to ask for a
solution to a more difficult problem
this arent problem over non-convex
losses yeah but but my question really
is how can you design a front end to the
d-wave machine without a good
characterization of what that machine
does okay so so this is unfortunately we
we should maybe talk how much longer I
should go because I was just sort of as
a reorientation point is exactly what
you ask so we have so far talked earlier
discussed the stack and it just happens
to be
we do more we have done more work in in
the upper part of of the stack because
if you so far we only have made it down
to a Cubo now this is still the Cubo
that's the hardware um sorry that the um
actually coming now to to the dve
processor this is the camera graph this
is how the cubits on the dve chip are
connected so so far I have actually
worked with fully connected quadratic
problems so they not um the connectivity
is not this funky cha um connectivity so
um yeah your non-convex uh situation
translates R into a Cubo yes so so we
get it into a Cubo um because that
sounds convex the quadratic optimization
no um quadratic optimization if you if
you're the Matrix that's in there is
nonpositive definite or non definite if
you have oh it's non definite I'm sorry
okay
okay um
yeah hard so
um what I meant to say earlier you're
completely right it's a necessary
condition for this whole thing to work
that the cubits and say the adiabetic
algorithm does a good job if if they
fail on let's say the hardware
realizable cubos we have nothing I mean
we we know we know that the machine is
really not executing Eddie's U adiabatic
algorithm would true if they had
coherence times like 10,000 times longer
than they do but with NC scale coherence
times they're doing something inspired
by the adiabatic algorithm maybe they
it's Quantum healing but I don't think
we really understand what it is that's
that's true so um what we could do is
since you it could jump forward to this
so so could I ask you something even
simpler can even I mean I like what you
have been telling us so far perhaps
because I know nothing about the subject
could you even tell me what motivates
you to even connect this with dwa what
has this got to do with the dwa machine
at all I'm not I'm just completely
stunned I mean I mean all the things you
told us yeah were done using regular
cluster machines it's a it's a it's a
very complicated optimization problems
in which a lot of people have made
advances over the years very clever
people
and what got he's trying to get away
from quadratic program so classical
machine is going to be Bott so
disconnect now now you want to do it by
some other technique which is
revolutionary and can much simp the
connection is such that as soon as you
let go of the convex relaxations you
wind up with and formly NP hard oration
problems of course I have a whole host
of solvers I can use I can use taboo
search clex HX and I can get solutions
for this and already as we saw it works
better often than what sort of system so
that's great that's a paper from machine
learning Don that's exactly what I'm
saying they accepted those papers just
on the ground that this is hey not a
good Improvement there however um we
know I already we went through the
effort to to to formulate it as
quadratic optimization so we M low not
having the spast connectivity which I
lost over which I haven't given you yet
um we
have here a machine that at least in
principle or we hope or there's some
evidence for it that it will on those
problems do better than classical so
there is a CL that the D machine can do
quadratic optimization that's what it
comes in yeah that's what I'm looking
for of course if that machine doesn't do
that then there's no one but I I have
formulated machine learning problems as
quadratic optimization which I can solve
classically but we know any classical
solver will scale exponentially as those
problems get larger and I cannot even
hope to be anywhere near the global
minimum we don't get this the zwave
machine promises to give me better
solutions to these problems than what I
can classically obtain and there's
evidence from various groups that indeed
the machine does this despite the con
room that how can it be doing anything
useful if the sweep time or the Nee time
is 5 microc Seconds and let's say the um
the coherence times are only 2 to four
NCS so we have this disconnect and I
have a few things to say about that I
could um actually the maybe I skip
skipped this before getting there I
still wanted to you asked me earlier hey
um isn't um don't you need as many
cubits or variables as you have examples
so for the regularizations that was
fortunately not the case but for the um
non-convex loss that's true I need to
have sort of the right Parabola for for
each um for each example I need at least
one auxiliary variable that's bad if you
have let's say a million a data set with
a million entries Is Not Unusual let
said you could scale all some 10 million
or 100 million so if I need that many
cubits I'm I'm in trouble I won't have
this for a long time to come so a lot
lot of our recent work has been how can
we get rid of the S dependence of the
number of variables we need and um
essentially what we we do here going I
need to express something like this the
overall loss is the sum of the sample
losses here my my Q loss so I sum those
up so this is really what and of course
the M as the definition we saw earlier
this really which buries is zws so I
need to express this guy with what's
given to me in in terms of the the vwa
graph and I want to do this with a
reasonable number of of cubits and not
necessarily at a function of s which
often gets too big so what we the
strategy that we came up with is the
following we say okay this is a sum over
s let's just look at a single example
and then if you can express a single
example say as a quadratic
function then I can later on just sum up
all the JS and all the ages so the um
quadratic coefficients and the linear
coefficients and I still have a
quadratic problem and uh but I have
Express what I'm interested
in um now I should have maybe said
something something earlier which maybe
all aware of um
but when you look at the d-wave hardware
graph in in principle this is a very
general format because um let's say if
you need connectivity between two cubits
that are not directly connected by a
physical connection yeah no problem you
just chain up a number of cubits through
pherom magnetic interactions and then
you get um first a higher degree of
connectivity and you can in theory
connect any two cubits this way any two
logical cubits this way um the bad thing
is to for you need auxiliary cubits for
this but even worse I'm not sure that
this news has made it um to you is that
as you connect let's say if you form
chains of cubits strongly
paramagnetically coupled then originally
the d-wave programming guide suggested
this as a strategy as I just described
um however now they say you shouldn't do
that why because you um you increase
your success rate you're doing something
that is ACH to A first order face
transmission because the logical Cubit
that's now consistent of a chain of the
physical Cubit and sort of to to
coherently tunnel all together and as
you make your chain longer the
probability for this rapidly decreases
so the D guys think um it's something
ACH to A first order phase transition I
think it's not really known yet Vadim
smanski saying that's not true and this
is rather a to a second order phase
transition and that's again will shrink
polom um if you do this but it's not
fully investigated and I just sort of
what in principle seem like a good
strategy has a clear physical barrier um
the other piece that you probably also
fully aware of let's say you want to do
third order
interactions that's in principle no in
theory again no problem if let's say I
would have had to do let's say three
weights and say W1 W2 and a W3 and then
I have in my objective functions terms
like this that's not what the d-wave
function can do it can only do um
quadratic terms then you
simply introduce an
auxiliary variable Z and then you ensure
using some lrange um penalty Z at all
times you have Z equal to W1 * W2
essentially adding to your objective a
Lage term
of this
nature and um then you can express
higher order terms and you can of course
stag this so fifth order term sixth
order terms are possible but of course
the number of auxiliary cubits you need
grows quite quickly so here is
essentially if you had n this would be
plus n too if you want to if you have
all these terms
realized but one thing that I think
there's no way around and that's why I'm
harping on even if the quantum stuff on
the bottom works all perfectly it's
still far away from easily solving
problems of the nature um I showed you
because if and say I have n variables
then a general objective function if you
wanted to express it would need two to
the N coefficients to express it even in
a fully connected Cubo you only have n
squar so that's wofly short of the 2 to
the N I need and even worse the um
d-wave chip has only every Cubit is
connected to um five no yeah five or six
other cubits that's only a linear number
of um coefficients that you have so the
expressivity of this guy is
unfortunately really low that so
and we have good evidence that on the
native formulat so if you give the
d-wave machine camera structured binary
optimization problem it does do better
than classical algorithms is
that the USC guys are seeing this our
own test we have seen this you have guys
are themselves are reporting it to to me
the the big unworked issue is that the
expressivity of this guy is so low so so
uh these are essentially here exercises
to sort of EK out as much as we can out
of this poor expressivity and here you
essentially see fits of the
qoss the Coss is blue guy and this is if
you if the D chip were to have only
first order terms you could express it
and you were to do this fitting
procedure you would get something like
that if you have second order third
order fourth order and so on you you get
of course better and better um fits but
you would need to use and this strategy
over here to then get rid of your higher
order terms so so what we investigating
right now is what is sort of the best
sort of the lowest set of
um of couplings we can get away with to
do a fit that is good enough to perform
sort of the job we needed to do and and
then an interesting finding the F was
more random thing is that if the X the
elements of your input vectors are sort
of uniform distributed you get these
types of fits but if you if they are
gaan distribute and that happens earlier
that was ear when you ask hey is there
some form of um data compression early
on if you would use the technique that's
called random projections and you just
use a you're familiar with it um then
actually you have this property that the
elements are G distributed and that fits
better so you have save a whole um order
here that's kind of nice we actually
found if it falls yet steeper like a
beta distribution certain parameters you
could do it perfectly with just two um
with second order but we are not aware
of encoding scheme that gives us that
property but it's interesting to to
realize that as your
um vectors have a certain property um
which you can achieve by using suitable
encodings it's better can be better
expressed a cub there less
error um okay so this is work in
progress and I we'll jump over this and
then maybe we finish with sort of what
we're seeing on the the hardware to
Connected finally to the hardware I
realize you will have Matias here as a
guest tomorrow so you might have other
people here who can tell you the latest
and greatest on specific experiments
that I'm just quoting here um so I don't
know whether you have seen this figure
so these are latest Benchmark tests um
provided by dawave and provided by USC
um the blue data points here are d-wave
they measure now up to 200 cubits the um
USC I think has 106 cubits on that chip
so so what does this figure show it
shows problem sizes of increasing so so
number of variables binary variables AA
in this case number of of cubits then
this uh the y axis shows the medium time
to find with 99% probability the best um
solution at this point here you can
still make the solution to
what to the cha structured optimiz um to
um so it's a quadratic optimization
problem it's a quadratic optimization of
this topology uh and given the dead
Cupid so the actual topology the
chip yeah okay ESS actually a few cubits
are said tend to be broken so it's even
a little worse than this so so imagine a
few cubits D yet so in in physics term
is this a variable J uhing model that's
been Sol it's a chimera structur ising
model I I don't know the word chimera I
mean I know
is that graph
okay do know that this is not aiz I
mean then then I understand everything
that's okay I mean that's good to do and
you know I me I'm not opposed to that
but it's good to agree mean it's a non
planer graph so you cannot efficiently
so this is this guy so actually you can
see this here they come compared it to
various euristic solvers so this year is
iterated taboo search is actually the
one that gave us the best results too
but then Sergio boo um was smart enough
he should have done that since long but
he just went to the latest Mex sub
competition and back up what's called AK
Max set which was a winner of the last
two um Mex set competitions and if you
would it's not shown here but it would
come out there a number I know is it
would come out about here it's at 512 if
you extrapolate this would be 40,000
this the D chip um War clock that is
um down here by the way I should explain
this figure some more down here is the
kneeling sweep alone wall clock has
these other
umly downloads the coefficients
thermalize it again uh readouts so
that's the difference between
so there just a constant shift between
the red dashed and the purple dashed
line I uh I have the exact breakdown
it's
pretty I'm not sure it's exactly con
could be linear programming time of the
chip cooling after the kind of but D
worse than linear d dve 2 doesn't have
those times anymore yeah there's no
calization time right right okay so this
is d one the difference
d there's no cooling after they're
actually doing it um conservatively so
as they as they download the program you
don't heat up the chip I see but they're
still plotting 192
K could show you
the 28 or something classical liit let's
forget about the purple curve I mean the
more interesting curve is the red one
and the little blue dots above it so the
blue dot but did you see that there's a
another curve that's not drawn here that
you were talking so of course you
compare this to classical solers and
this is this one here which not
surprising me this is an N problem the
um it's a straight line in this lck
linear um plot and but there is for this
type of problem Ser boy should bug up um
AK Max set which is a better classical
solver than um than iterated taboo
search so this would be a straight line
that would go up to here still the good
news is so it's not any more this 10
billion times faster um but it's still
at this point it would be 4,000 times
faster than a single core are those
exact classical solers or us classical
solers um these I I think the way how s
runs them he runs them until this is
extrapolation it couldn't do this up
somewhere here so we use actually from D
it's what we call the martial solver
it's a tree with solver and it's an
exact solver and it can find Solutions
without big gymnastics here into the 250
range actually with I forgot the number
of terabyte you just throw a number of
10 terabyte if you could access access
if you were your machine were to have
which they don't um have 10 TB of ram
then CPU standard CPU could still solve
this guy here again P structured in stre
minutes but you have to have access it
it's it's exponentially in the memory it
needs so we could probably still run
this on a larger serice Center at Google
and could get the Optimal Solutions here
um but right now and this those curves
are all extrapolated from sort of up to
here in
atmx so I'm trying to understand um when
you say median median time they are
looking at problem s with random
interactions between the cubits that's
correct pH this graph now how do we know
that most of those Solutions are really
trivial that's right which of course the
dway finds and that your particular
algorithms to find them are kind of toll
old overkill for solving those medium
because if this is a median time how do
we know that 50% of the problems they're
looking at are not trivial and that even
these better algorithms you know my my
my point my point is also that how do we
know that this the energy space of this
is not a funnel and you know whatever
d-wave does it's always going to find a
minimum solution it's only when it's
kind of like an a carton shape where
we're finding some really neat
interesting solution but if it's a
medium time my guess is that most of the
the things that they're they're uh
trying to compute are kind of trivial
unless you you prove that no no it's we
as them exactly that question to so it's
a good question sorry no it's it's a
very good question so so I discussed
this with extensively how we can better
test it and he came up with the uh
suggestion to I mean first we should
observe unfortunately for ma for
weighted Max two sub as opposed to let's
say uh three sub problems there's not um
um information phas transition as that
is known so we couldn't simply say let's
just go to hard instances by um going
near the informational phase transition
you could of course do let's say Define
your benchmarks in this reset space and
then by a method like this map it back
to um maxat max two set um and then you
would to some degree be assured that the
problems are harder there's another more
vertile meod so suggesting why don't we
just instead of looking at 100% of
selected um random instances we just
look at different percentiles we order
for each um size sort of we order it by
um exactly and then we look at the
percentiles is that scales let's say the
words takes the polinomial scaling
percentile out then we have some
assurance that um we only look at the
heart instances yeah that's right
because I would like to see this for
some kind of hard non-trivial hard
instances how does it do because since
it's median of random instances you know
I don't know what that means this is the
medium time so you know if 50% of the
instances are are relatively easy well
that's not going to change things I mean
it it would have to be
99.999% of instances easy I mean if if
half the instances take zero time that's
only get to lower the medium by factor
of two which you won't see on this large
scale and of course making the
assumption that the classical guys
stumble on those which is not
necessarily the case in our taboo search
if you have a submodel which sort of in
in continuous Spas would be a convex
problem so if you have a submodular
problem um taboo search would just do
fine on those as well so I don't think
even though the point is well taken I
don't think it will actually I was
discussing sort of acceptance criteria
with the D guys and they actually
worried about the opposite they say you
should not give us the easy problems
because that the classical solers can
pick up on um yeah I'm more worried
about the other extreme which is I've
seen data on d-wave ability to solve
instances of Max cut which gave sort of
a bobal distribution and I guess the way
the U time the finding solution was
expressed there was the probability of
finding a solution with One Sweep so you
do One Sweep which takes how many micros
seconds yes this I should have explain
to appreciate this figure The Sweep time
is fixed at 5 microc and then just take
more samp right but but my impression
was that there were instances that where
perhaps they never found a solution mhm
is that correct M well that would make
the median Infinity well
no this is
medum and not the I'm sorry I I was
wrong I agree with what you said I I was
read % of them are easy and look
good to me afterwards John I have
numbers for you okay
yeah the medum
too yeah that's that's really bad
statistic are you making your slides
available for this talk by the way I I
could do that so actually this one is
that one send that to me um he he
allowed me to use it I would have to
check I think by now it's already an
older gra and better ones are produced
that address actually points like you
are making by selecting hard problems so
the next this is just sort of three
slides of evidence that this thing has
some interesting Behavior this one I
should probably not talk about because I
understand one of the the aren't you
part of the the team that does that so
this is a work by S Boo and there's an
archive paper forth coming and I feel
like probably not talk about other folks
work but I likeed that experiment a lot
so I thought for those who don't know it
yet should so s and USD team um uh set
up a simple um 8 Cubit here's the num
the numbers here is Cubit 1 2 3 4 so
this simple um uh graph with um the ages
um and and JS as set to minus one + one
as a bias terms and then the coupling
term and then if you look at this you
will find that there is a 17 fold
degenerate ground state for this problem
and um so there's this one this is paper
I think where everybody is down spins
are down or spins are up and then this
one here the first four
are um down and then sorry I this up
better but there's sort of two groups
sort of one sort of stands on its own
and um the others are essentially
distinguishing those four Central cubits
and then this is relatively
straightforward and simple thing they're
doing they're setting up um a classical
simulated serm aning model and a Quantum
analing model to predict sort of the um
probabilities of measuring one of those
17 States and uh so s was telling me and
I think you're a member of this team can
please feel free to to jump in is
telling me that what they are seeing is
commensurate with the the quantum model
and I'm not on this this this different
experiment that we're doing so not this
one I see okay so that's um and this is
just essentially one example of multiple
So Daniel is doing work with simple um
qu error correction schemes and he says
even though that's not my focus all of
these my work is sort of an indirect
quantumness test so these schemes with
their work um tell me also that sort of
the quantum models underlying error
correction we apply on the chip um are
corrected to some degree
um and since time is shorten I'm sure
you guys have all studied this sort of
the papers themselves most notably the
tunneling experiment that was reported
um in in the nature publication I think
most of us looked at so I'm not going
through those so three blocks of
evidence and there's our own work where
we have um run um optimization problems
of the nature we um discussed using what
is called the blackbox solver of dwa I
don't like this approach for various
reasons essentially it is in spirit
similar to this where where essentially
you you have an objective function that
you're really interested in it may not
be cratic it may not obey the the
connectivity structure um that you um
that the hardware provides but you try
to do the best with the graph you have
so essentially you try to to f
you draw a number of of samples from
your hardware and then you compare you
look up the objective values that you
get in the objective function you're
interested in and you see whether
they're correctly ordered or not if
they're not correctly ordered you change
your JS and ages until this ordering um
is sort of as close as possible and then
you solve the Z resulting problem so as
an optimization GM okay that's just like
a funky second order mthod
second order methods are known to work
not too poorly it's reinforcement
learning they're solving a bment
equation is all they're doing really
what equation the bment
equation so we'll talk we'll talk later
but it is really traditional
reinforcement learning is what they're
doing so so so I can see the rationale
behind it but I think I don't like to
touch it at this point because you
really don't know when you get a better
solution did this have anything to do
with Quantum or if you would have had a
classical Sol underneath you just can't
discriminate here the fitting problem is
convex so you know um you you sure to
get the best fit and then you you give
it to the quum hardware but despite me
not liking this method this method was
able to outperform sort of the best
Solutions we could get for the classical
solvers
so yeah testimony that something good to
happen Okay so these are the three
pieces of of evidence let me just this
is actually the last slide before the uh
conclusions actually so so actually here
is I just quoted um Michel email he sent
me so say how can we understand that the
system with coherence times of 2 to four
n seconds
performs um the adiabetic agorism or
adiabetic analing when the analing time
is much longer than that 5 microc so so
what how can we understand this
obviously there's some evidence pretty
much anybody who touches the Chip And
reports back there is some performance
advantage that's being seen over
classical that's just that evidence is
there how can we understand it I mean
obviously for starbus we have to use
open systems quantum mechanics so so the
environment is crucial in this process
and we need to understand sort of um how
the system and environment interact to
maintain a certain let's say volman
distribution over the states that are
available to the system um um another
basic thing that's often overlooked is
that even though the density Matrix and
the energy Matrix might decohere become
diagonal that does not mean of course
that does not imply that the density
Matrix in the computational basis
becomes diagonal to and I'm a simple
example for that um so to
of course to do the right open open
systems um analysis of the system is
fairly involved whether you use red
block field or more complex um um
schemes of modeling this um yet there's
a bunch of papers from Muhammad Amin
that those of you interested this
question prob aware of there's also um
speak before coming IAL discuss this
with Vadim and he told me that the
easiest way maybe just tell your
audience that you can arrange the sweep
such that at all points during the
evolution you have a NE ballman
distribution in the system of a very
cold system so favoring the lowline
states and he is actually a month away
from um paper that provides the
conditions now that the kneeling sweep
or the noise characteristics in chip
need to fulfill for maintaining a bman
distribution during the evolution so
that's sort of at least I I don't give
you sort of here's why um but sort of
this is I give you sort of the style of
series that you need to come bring to
bear to understand this this conundrum
and um can I just make one comment on
this yeah please um I've been reviewing
a dway paper that kind tries to address
this yeah and
unfortunately it's um been rejected by
all the referees so I don't know when
it's going to be publicly available but
it's actually a fantastic experiment
that you goes into some of these details
so I can probably talk about this
privately uh and to say what what's
going on there but it's it's very
telling new entanglement experiments or
is this is the 16 Cubit
T um Z the two talk about it later but
there's some information I can bear here
yeah would love to to hear that so maybe
I conclude with this and and maybe I
hope nobody's offended going to this
super simple example but when I saw sort
of blog from Scott erens that he sort of
missed that point I thought maybe it's
it's worth it to even though it's super
simple um it's it gives you sort of a
notion or an inkling of what's going on
so if you were to just have a single
Cubit um with a single um holy um Matrix
um generated Honan then the energy I
States would look something like this we
have two energy IG values plus minus
Delta and half so two energy levels
separate by Delta so um I lifted this
from um uh work by Muhammad Amin so if
you look at the density Matrix in the
energy bases in the we coupling limit to
the environment the density Matrix would
look something like that you have a T1
and T2 times and then as T time goes
to Infinity you would see these would
get dampened out this the other e down
here so essentially um you with the
nonagonal terms disappear that is
essentially density Matrix becoming
diagonal this is the hor Mark the
definition of decoherence is the time
was which the non-diagonal terms
disappear and you are left with an
incoherent mixture and of course um
these terms essentially Al the elements
on the diagonal are the Balman
probabilities to see the system in
certain uh energy levels um but what's
important um to notice is this is a
picture in the energy basis now if you
transform this over to go into the
computation basis which is of course the
one of relevance here you see that the
um nonagonal terms reappear and so
essentially the probability of finding
the system in the higher energy level
minus the probability of finding it in
the lower energy level so this as long
as the temperature sort of is not too
high that those are almost the same that
indeed you have sort of typically
exponential um favored um lower energy
states as per bman this would not be
zero so there is um an signature of
coherence left in the computational
basis and of course strictly speaking if
the system would be perfectly cold then
you could start in an initial State
that's say where um
two State system is in just one but
that's that's a non- statement signature
of coherence is always left even at 10
microc with 1 nond coherence time the
the signature of coherence left it's
only e to^ - 5,000 that's that's the
level it's left this is a quantitative
question so I do not quite understand
what point is being made by changing Bas
writing some equations so even I mean
you know Michael's question the original
question yeah I mean at 10 micr with one
n def phasing you have some coherence
left it's Justus 1,000 you cannot do
much with it so what I want to see is
some numbers for the specific Cas to say
some sign coherence is left is a
mathematical statement which doesn't
have much content for anything real see
what I'm getting it I mean I want to
know what those numbers are I mean for a
realistic situation that's why I started
out just according to number of papers
again we don't do work in this area but
you what I'm asking right I mean I mean
I don't disagree at all some signature
of coherence you know it's an
exponential process in fact it's often
not even exponential some power comes in
all the details matter
but I think the Z Els won't be small I
mean I
think well this model is way too
simple I I mean I think the point is if
something becomes diagonal in the sigma
Z basis then it's not diag on the sigma
X basis of course yeah yeah what I'm
saying this is a simple model and nobody
will disagree with that question is that
in the realistic situation what is going
on and this doesn't answer that question
yeah I mean this for example there a
whole say in the weak coupling limit
this depends on the type of noise that's
present and really complex and um it's a
bit of a Dark Art open system quantum
mechanics models but folks who I trust
who know these things like Vadim he
tells me I I think I can show you the
conditions under which the stays balsman
and of course in the in the let's say
Mak an extreme case let's say we have
two levels close to each other and
realistic systems don't look like this
but never as for argument sake if the
ground state one excited state and some
Gap here the other states third fors
higher up so if you have a very cold
system um then you might just see a
population just of these two states and
in terms of coherence time I think it's
not the right language to to discuss it
sure you can pick up a phonon or a
photon and then jump to the first
excited state and then sort of you you
had some level of of decoherence
happening yet sort of your success prob
probability or getting a good solution
is is very high so as long as the system
is cold enough
there's yeah you can expect something
good to happen because yeah the full
model of this um is yeah we are still
awaiting
this but as if we see sort of in other
systems let's say m m m who is working
um
photosynthesis and he just sent me an
proposal to look at envir Quantum
assisted stochastic Computing where sort
of the idea is that the environment
plays a crucial role to um bring about
or preserve the Quantum Resources
necessary so while we we and obviously
there I think by now it's accepted as
that coherent transport occurs sort of
in a warm and wet cell in Vivo I think
we just haven't fully understood the
open systems quanum mechanics well
enough yet to appreciate to what degree
are the resources we care for preserved
and what is preserved is it relevant
enough to speed up the computations in a
time we care for um I mean in general
for Quantum computation this is not
something I'm very familiar with it's
not relaxation that's as important as
defacing itself often they the same
thing but there are situations where the
temperature could be very low so you
don't have almost any energy relaxation
but you have
defacing and defacing is what um doesn't
seem to matter here that's the claim I I
I fully fully understand that but I
think that's because of the topology a
model that is chosen for defacing
doesn't matter in general it matters so
what one would like to I'm not
questioning that for this model it
doesn't matter but in general for a
physical model defacing would matter is
is the point I'm making but but in my
little s example that why I brought up
with the two levels you can can have
complete def phasing between those
States and you still would get a very
good result in the computation so that
seems to be evidence that def phasing
can or is not an or phase coherence to
say it positively is not a necessary
condition to get a good result in
your I I I might disagree with that in
the sense that if you have a
multi-dimensional and you know you have
a state multi-dimensional state and
somehow you get an an Crossing okay then
you what you're worried about is the gap
and if you have a lot of Def phasing my
guess is that that Gap is going to get
smaller and smaller and make it less
likely that you'll stay on the ground
state it's just just a guess what that
def phasing could lowers the gap of the
anti
Crossing okay is
that with
that it this and then you I mean again
hard I mean I can make comments on this
thing I didn't work on it but I find it
very difficult to accept that there
could be General situation so you have a
lot of defacing and you still can remain
a diabetic and you give an example how
diabet should could be lost for example
I think theave claim is not that it uh
successfully transits this uh tiny Gap
in St in the ground state it does I
think they admit that it goes into the
excited state but then they believe
there's some kind of Decay process that
takes it down to the ground state which
is why C in The
Bu I I the paper I was talking about
that I
reviewed looked at an anti Crossing in
good detail so there's experimental
evidence of what's going on with the
single an Crossing that we we should
talk about in
right actually is there any more
comments from anyone else in the room
about this you want to say anything
about theer stuff simulated or no yeah
but that's it's kind of it's one of
those open open system models so it's
yeah we can discuss it day
maybe a lot of later
yeah I guess we've been setting a very
peculiar model mhm so we we need to
think about how how it
applies particular not the
C well should we end the uh actually
we've ask you a lot of questions yes
this is the last that's the summary so
so just to go through it also as you
realize I'm I put the picture with the
stack up in the beginning so I'm working
more the upper part of the stack you
know how do I assuming sort of all this
the Sausage Factory underneath there
turns out to
work
satisfactorily then how do I sort of get
into the entrance door and and to map my
problems into the format I need so I
think what we saw is is that non-convex
anorm regularization leads to more
accurate and compact
classifiers I think we discuss exciting
results that with non-convex losses you
can achieve robustness um up to 50%
against up to 50% labor noise um and the
good news was that training was
non-convex regularization but still
convex loss very naturally maps to Cubo
in the sense that we do not need a lot
of auxiliary Vari
we're still struggling to map the
non-convex loss onto the available
Hardware graph we have a scheme that
works but it uh demands the number of
auxiliary variables um of the order of s
of course you can always do what machine
learning people do in such situations
this problem occurs actually in
classical context too you could do um
what um people are online learning so
you look at a batch of 100 and next
batch of 100 next batch of your 100
examples but of course Never As Good As
looking at all examples at the same time
um so we are still struggling to get
this down onto the hardware graph with
not too large number of
variables okay that's it thank
her